i am a cookbook fanatic and major
collector
but here's someone we love to show you a
dish
we think you'll want to make for your
next meal
hi drew natalie here from the modern
proper and i'm going to show you how to
make our super easy vodka sauce for
dinner tonight
first add in a tablespoon of olive oil
follow it up with a cup of
onions half a pound of pancetta and stir
that until everything is soft and crispy
add in three garlic cloves minced and
stir just until fragrant
follow it up with a half a cup of vodka
and one can of whole tomatoes crushing
them with your hands as you add them to
the pot stir
and allow everything to get nice and
thick as it simmers
add in red pepper flakes a teaspoon of
salt and stir until combined
follow it up with 3 4 cup of heavy cream
a cup and a half of parmesan cheese
and stir until you have a nice thick
creamy sauce
serve the sauce over your favorite pasta
and top with fresh parmesan
thinly sliced basil and maybe even a few
pepper flakes
hi drew i'm alice choi from hip footy
mom and today i'm going to show you how
to make my delicious korean
spicy pork tacos we are going to be
using korean gochujang which is a hot
pepper paste
we also have honey we have ginger we
have garlic we have soy sauce
we've already whisked everything up i
have some pork shoulder
in my pressure cooker that i've already
browned and now i'm going to add my
sauce directly
in and we're gonna cook this on high
pressure for 50 minutes i'm gonna shred
up the pork we're gonna layer in
some of this delicious korean pork and
now we're gonna add in some fresh
lettuce and you can have korean tacos
without
kimchi i'm also gonna add in some sesame
seeds some
green onions some fresh radishes and
i'm going to drizzle this with a
homemade gochujang sauce
and there you have it my spicy cream
pork tacos you can find the full recipe
at hipfootiemom.com
drew thank you so much for having me i
had a blast
i'm alex from the defined dish and i'm
going to show you how to bake this easy
italian white bean soup for your next
meal
first let's start with some oil in a
large pot over medium heat and cook some
bacon next
add the onion celery garlic
chili flakes and a pinch of salt and
pepper give that all a good mix
and cook for about 5 minutes
now add some white wine
beans and broth
next add the cheese rind rosemary
oregano
bay leaf lemon zest and of course
salt and pepper once it boils reduce the
heat
and let it simmer for 25 minutes
when that's done add in some spinach
lemon juice and cook about five more
minutes
finally top it off with parmesan and
parsley and enjoy
today we're gonna make a delicious
mushroom marsala
it's a fantastic side dish for upcoming
holiday meals
or any weeknight meal first chop one
pound of mushrooms
then add one tablespoon of butter to a
pan
add the mushrooms and saute over
medium-high heat
for about two to three minutes next
add two minced garlic cloves and stir to
combine
then add one teaspoon of thyme half
teaspoon of kosher salt
and a quarter teaspoon of black pepper
stir and cook for one to two minutes
before adding the marsala wine
turn up the heat to high and bring it to
a boil
just for about two to three minutes next
you're going to add the remaining two
tablespoons of butter
and cook until most of the liquid has
dissolved
and the mushrooms turn this beautiful
dark brown
glaze happy thanksgiving drew lauren
palmer here to show you how to make
cheesy brussels sprout and bacon bake
the first thing you'll need to do is to
trim the ends and quarter about a pound
of brussels sprouts
drizzle with olive oil season with salt
and roast until slightly charred and
tender
next in a medium pan saute a sliced
onion and half a pound of bacon
until crispy and caramelized add a
splash of sherry vinegar and the roasted
brussels sprouts
next you'll want to combine some
softened cream cheese gruyere
and mozzarella with fresh thyme and
grated nutmeg
fold in the brussels sprout mixture and
bake until cheesy golden brown and
delicious
happy thanksgiving drew cheers
[Music]
yum i cannot wait to eat that
[Music]
you